what would happen if you fell into a
black hole
if you'd asked albert einstein he would
have told you that according to his
general theory of relativity
you'd be sucked into the black hole
singularity the point where space-time
curves steeply
inward and all the laws of physics seem
to break down
after that nothing can escape in the
1970s
stephen hawking took a semi-classical
approach to black holes
bringing together quantum theory and
einstein's relativity
he proved that black holes emit a small
amount of heat that eventually causes
the black hole to evaporate
still according to hawking if you fell
into a black hole
you and your particles would be lost to
the universe forever
this is don page he was a postdoc with
stephen hawking where they became
friends
despite the fact that they ultimately
landed on either side of one of the most
controversial
debates in modern physics i looked at
hawking's argument and became not
convinced by it
hawking's work implied that black holes
violated a central principle of quantum
mechanics
called unitarity which says that the
present always preserves information
about the past so how could it be
possible that black holes destroy
information this became known as the
black hole
information paradox and for decades it
made physicists queasy
according to page if you were to fall
into a black hole
you wouldn't be gone for good particle
by particle
the information needed to reconstitute
your body would re-emerge
well it would be highly scrambled by the
black hole it'd be much worse than
even you know if you just cremated the
body and
and it turned into smoke and ashes but
you know another analogy is if you burn
up a book
and you have all the ashes the
information is still somewhere there is
somewhere in the universe we believe
the key to understanding why the
information is preserved lies in a
process called quantum entanglement
when black holes emit radiation that
radiation maintains a quantum mechanical
link to its place of origin
if you tried to measure the radiation or
the black hole separately
the information would look random but
when you look at them together
they exhibit a pattern you know if
somebody took a coin and and
and cut it in half and then you sort of
shook it up and put it in two envelopes
and send it off to two people
then of course there would be what we
call correlations in it if one person
gets a head they know the other person
would have tails
and this this quantum entanglement is
like that except it's an even more
subtle
this is the page curve which he created
to track changes in the entanglement
between a black hole
and its radiation as it ages the degree
to which the information is entangled
is called its entanglement entropy
at the start of a black hole's life its
entanglement entropy is zero
since it hasn't emitted any radiation
and at the end
its entanglement entropy is zero again
since the black hole has evaporated
but in between as radiation trickles out
the entanglement entropy grows
page showed that in theory information
can escape from a black hole
[Music]
in a series of groundbreaking papers
physicists have shown that the
entanglement entropy of black holes
really does
follow the page curve these calculations
give more evidence that indeed
the information does come out but the
details of how that actually happens and
you know still remain to be remain to be
understood and it
of course it raises the picture that
maybe space time itself is not
fundamental maybe there's something
deeper than space time and maybe the
basic quantum
description will involve something
that's not space and time
so i think there'll be parts of the
puzzle i think that'll persist for many
more decades
another puzzle that's baffled the
scientific community for decades
is super conductivity when various
solids are cooled to extremely low
temperatures
they can conduct electricity without
losing energy
this happens because the freezing
temperature allows electrons to move
slowly enough
to overcome their natural repulsion with
each other and they begin to form pairs
like any good couple should they balance
each other out and begin to move in the
same direction
when this happens electrical resistance
disappears
this is what makes superconductivity the
holy grail of energy efficiency
if only scientists could overcome the
limitations of temperature
this is ranga diaz this year he and a
team at the university of rochester
created a metallic compound that for the
first time exhibited superconductivity
at room temperature
so you have a very small two diamond
tips
that's sitting opposite to each other
and then you uh put
your sample that you need to study in
between those diamond tips
so you can apply force mechanically
diaz's team applied pressures
almost as extreme as those found at the
earth's core they did this by crushing
the compound inside a microscopic niche
they carved out of a diamond anvil
then they triggered chemical reactions
with a laser beam
so that way we were able to really find
the room temperature superconducted you
know it's under pressure right
what we have found is under pressure so
somebody can argue that okay so you went
from one extreme to another extreme so
so who cares so you know what's a big
deal in that sense right
uh but i i i think there was a time that
we were even the the scientists were
thinking that room temperature
superconducted is not possible
um to be honest in the very first time
when i when we saw this one i didn't
really believe it
and it was like okay this is too good to
be true and why we are seeing this nice
resistance everybody around the world
contact me
via email or phone calls and they were
very excited and
this is a landmark discovery but there
are a lot of you know a lot of work to
be done
because even though we know the initial
composition you know
what are the material that we put
together to pressurize it
but we don't know actually what it is
really what the sample is
superconducting so that those studies
need to be done
so for now levitating trains lossless
power transmission and perfect energy
storage are still
utopian dreams but diaz believes they're
not far off
i would say i'm very optimistic probably
in the next five years or ten years
may be able to get to a real application
in 2006 an astronomer detected a brief
and extremely powerful radio signal
coming from a distant galaxy
over the next few years dozens more were
observed
astronomers traded wild theories trying
to explain them this year
a fast radio burst was observed again
but this time it came within our own
galaxy
in just a millisecond the source emitted
100 million times more power
than the sun brian metzger and his
colleagues at columbia university
analyzed the data
and found the source a magnetar
so magnetar is a neutron star so neutron
stars form
when massive stars die at the end of
their lives the core of the star
collapses in and forms a neutron star
a very compact object about the mass of
our sun but the
size of new york city and then the outer
layers of the star explode as a
supernova so so neutron star is what's
left over and magnetar
is an extreme version of a neutron star
with a very strong
magnetic field so there was a magnetar
in our own galaxy that produced
a flare of x-rays and
arriving on earth at essentially the
same time as the x-rays was a burst of
radio emission which if we put it into a
different
distant galaxy would have looked a lot
like a fast radio burst
but we were you know identifying that it
came from a magnetar within our own
galaxy so that's pretty good
circumstantial evidence
you know that magnetars can produce fast
radio bursts
that's radio bursts are great because we
can see them almost to the edge of the
universe
and so in addition to actually
understanding what's producing them
one of the exciting things is we can use
them as as probes
of the state of matter between us and
the and the radio source
and so i think that's you know very
exciting as we discover more and more
fast radio birds
um and if it turns out that they that
they come from magnetars then we're also
probing
uh where all the magnetars are in the
whole universe which is something we
didn't think
you know was would have ever been
possible
you